hello everyone and welcome to game
number four of the 2013 World Chess
Championship match between vishwanathan
anand and magnus carlsen you already
seen three games all of the three games
were drawn and game number three was
especially a very nice fighting game
where Anand was on the attack but could
not you know bring home a whole point
here you will see a different type of
game as in game two you've seen on and
opened with e4 and calls and try to the
country four with the caro-kann defense
but here Carson will use one of the
specialties of his second young Ludwig
hammer and he will employ the Berlin
defense so it will be a very exciting
game and a very exciting you know day
and it's interesting garry kasparov also
visited Chennai in Tamil Nadu on game
three and four and there will also be an
interview with Garry Kasparov along with
the usual press conference after the
game I will put a link in the
description below with both the press
conference and also the interview with
Garry Kasparov so be sure to check that
out and as we do I don't have a photo of
this game but I did take this screenshot
from the official video I will put a
link to the official video also in the
description below the video lasts for
some five-and-a-half hours it covers the
entire game with the official commentary
so if you have a five and a half hours
to spare you know there are there are
worst way worse ways to spend them and
also I prepared two very interesting
photos for this video here is a photo
that really shows how much support
Carson is getting from his home country
of Norway so you know surely a gesture
such as this one will lift the spirits
of the 22 year old challenger and also a
very interesting photo I found is a
photo of the diet the players have been
eating so there you have it what
Carson's been eating throughout this
match and what Arnold was has been
eating throughout this match and Allen's
you know meal plan is pretty usual I
don't know
many of you may notice or may not know
this Anand is a vegetarian for a very
long time but it's interesting well you
can pause the video and read the entire
thing I will just read out the thing
that interested me the most so if you
can see here Magnus Crossan and go to
dinner here he it says at the end of
dinner usually pasta into two slices of
pizza now I'm pretty sure never in my
life have I had pasta with two slices of
pizza but you know as Carlson did win
this World Chess Championship match you
know you should definitely consider
having pasta and two slices of pizza for
dinner if you have an important date
tomorrow as obviously cousin know
definitely knows what he's doing so
let's check out this very exciting game
and I'm pretty sure I forgot to turn
down the sound okay I did there we have
it so let's check it out
Anand opens with E for and here we have
it 'if I've so not going with c6 as in
Game two with the kurakin defense Knight
to f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5 the rule
opus and the immediate Knight to f6
khasinau goes for the Berlin defense as
advised by his second young Ludwig
hammer
we have castles Knight captures on e4 d
4/9 to d6 Bishop captures on c6 d
captures d captures on e5 Knight to f5
and Queen captures on b8 King captures
and this position has been played so
many times and it was analyzed
thoroughly so h3 Bishop to d7 and now
rook to d1 and here the usual idea is
King to see it and you will most likely
always see this move when faced with
rook to d1 but here Crossing goes for
Bishop to e7 and this is known to be a
specialty of his second you'll move the
camera we have Knight to c3 and now that
the night is on c3 it's definitely time
for King to move to move away from the D
file so King to c8 now comes the Bishop
to g5 and h6 Bishop captures and Knight
captures and now look to d2 a4 is also
an idea here but there there is a known
game that
Costin second mr. hammer played with the
black pieces and he achieved a very nice
victory against this a4 move so probably
Anand knows this as instead of this a
formal move he goes for rook to D - we
have c5 and now Knight to e4 followed by
b6 defending the c5 phone was also
played plenty of times but here aren't
goes for a novelty plays rook a to d1
that was upon the D file attacks cousins
bishop on d7 and it's it's a very nice
position I was so far not seen in the
Berlin defence Bishop to e6 getting out
of the way
Knights to e1 now comes from 9th to g6
and the Knights to d3 Hungary maneuvers
the knight from every the d3 and also
now attacks the c5 pawn b6 defending and
now Knight to e2 as you will see in an
interview after the game if you check it
out in the description below and we'll
characterize this move as well as sort
of a mistake because he allows Bishop
captures and a2 and he thought that this
was impossible but such as my title of
the video suggests it it kind of reminds
you of another World Chess Championship
game a game won from the match official
versus Basque in Reykjavik in 1972 our
Spassky offered a poison pawn at the
Fisher and Fischer grabbed it and then
Fischer lost the game here on the other
hand it's a bit different here
Carlson does play Bishop captures an e2
and he allows the b3 to trap his Bishop
but here is a difference that the bishop
is actually not trapped here Carlson
place c4
we have Knight d2 c1 now attacking the
bishop we have pawn captures see captors
on v3 and now the shop the b1 and now
Bishop has an escape path so for some
reason uh none missed this and he
blundered upon we have F for defending
the e5 pawn rook to d7 doesn't really
work because the knight will not go for
this immediately rather roopd g8 will be
played and now rook to f7 will simply be
met with Knights captures on e5 and it
will be a very nice position for black
so after Bishop to be one F for the
the pawn and the Knight is guarding the
f4 pawn kink the b7 preparing to bring
the other rope into the game and now
Knights the c3 attacking Carlson's
Bishop on b1 Bishop to f5 and now g4 we
have Bishop to c8 and not Knights to d3
and although Anand did lose upon their a
call since pieces are still very
inactive and Anand is getting a lot of
contra play in for the price of one
point cousin plays h5 we have f5 now
Knight to e7 and now Knight to b5 and
here H captures on g4 is played and this
is one of the positions where on and
once again could have taken advantage of
the position like you've seen in the
previous game but here he doesn't here
he immediately recaptured H captors on
g4 a nicer idea was rook to c2 a nice
in-between move that attacks has c7 but
it's you know it's easy to say okay Roxy
to everyone can see this but the problem
is Knight to c6 and then there's really
nothing to do here well except there is
well in order to find this continuation
you have to find nice to be for here now
there's once again a double attack on
the c6 Knight and if you move the knight
there's a double attack on the c7 point
this is the idea you have to see you
have to sacrifice it to be for night
night capture some before and now rook
captures on c7 with check King the b8
and now rook captures on f7 and this is
the idea your sacrifice to pawn a piece
but this rook on a 8 is still completely
out of the game and you have a very very
strong very very strong to connect to
connected passed pawns okay one passed
pawn but they are two connected pawns
and this point will be very dangerous
when it starts marching forward
the problem with Bishop captures and i-5
is it doesn't work because you get knife
to d6 now attacking this bishop and also
threatening checkmate on g7 so there's
no way to give back the material at
alleviate you know your pain now there's
a threat of checkmate here and the only
way to stop it is Bishop to c8 and now
six and it's gonna be very hard to
prevent a seven and a eight so this is
the one of one idea on the mist in this
game he played the immediate H captures
on g4 and now rook to h4 by Carlsen nice
to have two defending the g4 pawn and
now Knight to c6 a6 was also possible
attacking the knight but then you get a
nice the d6 check sacrificing the
temporarily sacrificing the night after
captures you get captures attacking e7
night after night moves then d7 and
white white will grab back material and
will retain a very nice active position
so after night 2 f2 Knight to c6 by
Carlsen we have rook to c2 now
pressuring that c7 pawn once again a 5
and now rook the c4 here on and stops
calls and from further pushing this a4
pawn and doesn't allow him to activate
his rockin a8 g6 a terrible mistake for
black here would be to actually capture
the f5 one with the idea that of course
if G characters then rook captures on h4
because the rope here is unprotected but
now Anand would have rook captures on c6
seems like a very nice idea
King captures and now not immediately
capturing the bishop because then King
would capture Knight Rider
tonight the d4 check King has to move
and now Knight will pick up the rock the
pawn the bishop and then you have to 2
nights for a rock and a white will
definitely have compensation here so
after rook to see for G sex by Carlsen
we have roped the c1 and now Bishop to
disown defending the knight on and c6 we
have e 6 trying to move the bishop away
from the defense of the night and c6
pawn captures pawn captures and the ship
has to go to e8 now Knight to e4 a very
nice idea by Anand that sacrifices the G
for pawn with a check but the knight
will be very strong we have rook to g4
check King f2 and now rook to f4 check
King to e3 and now rook goes back to f8
nice the d4 now there's a triple attack
on c6 Knight we have Knight captures
only move and
now rook captures on c7 with a check so
grabbing back at the pawn king to a six
and now King captures on d4 we have
roped to d8 with check King to c3 King
to e5 seems like a much more active
Square for the King to support your past
each sex pawn but you know there's the
active King and there is the to active
King because King g5 runs into rock to
f5
checkmate and this would be a terrible
way you know to to end a World Chess
Championship magic game so after Luke
the a check King to c3 and now comes
Rock to f3 check King b2 and now rook to
e3 attacking the knight
we have roped the c8 forcing a trade
rook to d3 Carson is still trying to to
play this position we have Luke 2:8
check King to b7 a very nice idea not
immediately allowing rook captures
Bishop but first
forcing the King back because you don't
want to allow black to start pushing
those pawns to be protected by the king
so first the rook to e8 sure King moves
and only now capturing the crossings
bishop we have rook captures night there
are no tricks with rook capture some be
three because the King escapes we have
looked to see - of course the king will
not go to a two so rook captures night
we have e 7 and now rook to g3
we have rook the c3 offering a trade of
rooks rook to e2 check rub the c2
blocking and now rook to e3 once again
threatening to capture on b3 King gay -
we have before a g5 rub the D - and now
rook to e5 rook to d7 this comes with
check King to c6 attacking the rook and
now rug defense the threat is now of
course he ate promoting the pawn to
Queen doubling up rooks and the e-file
not allowing point to e8 we have rook to
d6 check King moves and now other rook
checks on d7 King to a6 and now Rob to
d5 we have rook to eat too
this comes with check King to e3 and now
rook to e6 and here rook to d8 is played
of course
rook captures and g5 is not possible if
you capture the
former captors ng5 then you get b5 and
there is no defense against before
whatever move black plays white place
doesn't really matter before is coming
and then rook to a2 will be checkmate
so after rook to e6 rook to d8 we have
g4 now rope to g5
here comes rook captures on e7 we have
rookie check King moves and now rook
back to g8 a for rock captures on g4 we
have punky after some b3 and cousin does
have to pause to extra points but they
are two two doubled pawns and blacks and
cousin scheme is very inactive here so a
rook a to g7 King to a6 rogue characters
rook captures and here comes King
captures on b3 and here the game ended
as the players agreed to a draw cross
and does have an extra point but there
is no way to actually do anything here
there is no way to make progress with
the King or pawn after you give a check
simply King before and there there is no
progress to be made here if you start
pushing then white will push the King
back so of course this is a drawn
endgame and both of the players know
this so yeah this is game number four of
the World Chess Championship match
versus cross and in 2013 I do hope you
enjoyed it and like I said to check out
the links in description below if you
want to learn some more you know further
increase your vast knowledge about this
match check out the official press
conference and a nice interview with
Jarek as part of about you know things
in general about chess and how things
are finally back to the way they should
be you know there are there are no
knockouts in the World Chess
Championship Series
you know they returned to the match
format and it's a very interesting I
really do suggest you check it out
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon with a
very interesting game 5 of the 2013
World Chess Championship match between
Vishwanath an animal and Magnus Carlsen
thank you all and I'll see you soon